So we have first a convolutional layer.
And we'll talk about filter.
and then we'll talk about
pooling
Of which there are two types. There's average pooling and Max pooling.
So suppose we have and here.
I'm going to write some math from
this book this by the way.
I know I promise to share the list of books. Well, let
me just point this out now because I have it here.
This is one of the best.
Written books on machine learning and especially neural network
just this one.
Muhammad Zaki
data mining machine learning
I mean this book is just
Pleasant to read
book the book gradually built on.
basic concepts and workshops we are
I highly recommend you get this book.
Either when physical form or digital form, so let me
show you the way they used the
notation here.
or convolution
we'll begin with a one-dimensional convolution and then we can
extend that idea to a two-dimensional.
Matrix
The suppose we have two vectors.
I'm going to slightly adapt adapter writings here.
Now a picture is a matrix, but let's begin with one dimensional
first.
with
the components, you know x sub 1 x sub 2, etc,
etc.
And we have
a filter Matrix of excuse me. We talk
about the vectors. This is one dimensional for now.
So in one dimension
comfortable
Lucian now this book uses w
because a
while we are convolving it with with a filter.
Vector or a filter Matrix the components of
a filter Vector of filter Matrix are really awaits. So
it makes sense. I will also use the same convention. We'll make
this w
and it will be weights.
Now what you need to know, is that the number
of components?
or the dimension of the weight
and features
are not the same.
And here's I'll write down the mathematical notation,
but then I'll show two pictorial. It's very simple concept.
Now we denote a kind of evolution with an asterisk.
So we take our two vectors xnw we will
perform an element wise operation on the
components of both vectors. So we have x sub
k i and then I think this is
ODOT. And so this dot
inside the circle is the element wise operation. What we
are going to do is we will take
let's say
now x sub K refers to a
section of the vector
Let me show you let me show you let me show you here.
And it's okay for me to show you this picture page because the author
actually made the slides many parts
of this page available online for free.
iOS, try to find
The link I think if we Google thank
you the website will show up.
So I look up the slides the slides are quite helpful.
I mean the author did it tremendous job of
explaining these Concepts pictorially. Yeah, so
this is the cover of the book.
Now, let me jump to that section.
There we go. So this is our Vector. Yes. This is
what I mean by sub.
section of the vector
so if your filter is one by three
vector
what you are going to do?
Is do an element wise.
multiplication so one times one three times
zero
one times negative 2
and then the sum of that.
Same thing here.
three times one
two times two. So three times one is three two times two is
four. Obviously the zero cancels this other one out so
it gets seven.
Now if you notice here, there's a fourth
term.
the term stride
A stride is how many well strides you're
taking?
In the vector like how many strides if
imagine this is your vector?
This your vector. How many strides are you going?
Like how many?
Components are you skipping?
I mean, it's pretty clear in this picture here. The stride is one.
So initially the window if the filter was multiplying this
first three components and then
we take a one strike down.
And then we do an element wise operation.
And then we continue this way until we've covered
the entire.
vector
this is the product.
Or the result of this kind of evolution operation.
And this is what that notation is representing
when I say x for example, except One X up to
x sub 3.
Okay.
So X of three is the number of components your
multiplying this corresponds the three your
subscript code response to the size of the filter here.
Don't know by w.
so the first subsection the second subsection third subsection
and you are going to
add
The result of this element wise operation. That's what
you're seeing here. So this sum
is that value this sum is that value
and so on and then you will sum up all of
these together.
So you're going to add up?
negative 1 7 5 4 negative 1
and this will be put into another Matrix. So
if I can scroll down here.
Let me jump to and show you the 2D version. So this
is 2D convolution.
Right here.
There we go. Same idea.
This is applicable to what we are doing.
Okay.
again
Even in this example we're going in strides of
one so multiply element-wise right
the order.
Well and no notice. This is an identity Matrix.
So which means the numbers on the
principal diagonal of this subset?
Will be What Remain and they will be added together. So
one times one?
two times zero is going to cancel out three times zero is going
to cancel out one times one add these together you get to
then we take one story to the right.
So we are looking at the
picture so to speak by taking a strike you're scanning
the picture.
And the numbers we the there was
a and the numbers you would pick in the weights depend.
On how you want to look at the picture because for
a model to look at a picture.
Or is to look at vertical lines
or horizontal lines or
diagonal lines.
So if you look so that's why we have multiple filters because
we want to look at the picture from different. Let's say
angles and then add up everything. We
see everything the model sees.
Same thing here two times one.
That's two it's sorry two times one is two four times
one is well four.
So 4 plus 2 is 6 there's zeros.
Eliminate 21. I think you get the idea, right?
And of course we can then take this and do this for to a
tensor, which is a stack of matrices.
Okay.
That's all a kind of Illusion is.